les six opérations de chirurgie
cardiaque qui ont été réalisé la semaine
dernière à l'aide d'un robot ont mise en
avant les fantastiques progrès techniqu
réalisés ces dernières années et il
existe d'autres innovations comme la
téléchirurgie la possibilité en fait
d'opérer avec une incision de quelques
millimètres seulement et bien cette
technique est française et c'est dans le
cadre de l'Institut de la recherche
contre le cancer de Strasbourg qu'elle
est enseigné à des chirurgiens venus du
monde entier reportage Jérôme Soulard
Patrice
Schumacher
l'exercice est périlleux opérer un colon
dans le ventre d'un malade ouvert à
peine sur quelques dizaines de
millimètres'il plaît l mun et Strasbourg
TR intervention délicate en direct par
vidéonférence ce matin 160 spécialistes
viennent se former à la chirurgie
laparoscopique chiri àésent
mini l'appareil digestif du patient
quant au geste et à sa précision on l'
prend ici à Strasbourg actuellement
stade de la codification du geste
chirurgical c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
les réunions qui sont organisées ici
sont pour transmettre des messages
parfaitement codifi afin que le geste
soit reproductible entre toutes les
mains et en 4 ans 3000 chirurgiens ont
été formés à l'heure de cette
technologie
française je pratique déjà la chirurgie
laparoscopique au Japon
mais je viens apprendre en France les
nouvelles
techniques c'est vraiment une formation
excellente et nous aimerions beaucoup
installer le même centre chez nous à New
York
City l'Institut de téichirurgie de
Strasbourg c'est la théorie bien sûr
mais également la pratique dans cette
pièce 17 tables d'opération et des ports
normalement destiné à l'abattoir comme
le matin on traite un cancer du colon
grâce aux experts toutes les questions
ont immédiatement une
réponse la dissection de proche en
proche jusqu'à l'endroit où le mésère du
va rejoindre le mère de
l'intestinon la chirurgie par vidéo et
bientôt par ordinateur interposé c'est
la médecine du 3è millénaire auquel
l'Institut strasbourgeois est déjà
préparé la chir laparoscopique faisit
peur il y a 10 ans des chirurgiens
conservateurs disaient que cette
chirurgie n'aurait aucun avenir vous
voyez ce qu'elle est devenue elle s'est
généralisée donc c'est évident que si le
geste aidé par ordinateur est un plus
pour le malade et bien elle va se
systématiser des pathologies enfin
soignées limitant les problèmes
post-opératoires pour les malades c'est
le défi de cette technologie inventée
par les Français optimisée aujourd'hui
par les chercheurs du monde entier